Don't let appearances fool you.
This may look like an average office,...
...and Shigetaka Kurita may look like an average guy,...
...but odds are he's changed your life.
Meet the man behind the emoji.
The first emojis are far from what we use today.
Kurita designed them while working for telecom company NTT Docomo in the 1990s.
Using just a simple 12 x 12 pixel grid, 176 original emojis were born...
...and so was a new form of visual communication,...
...the very first one: a heart.
When you're creating it,...
...do you expect it to ever become such a universal language used by so many people?
No, I didn't think so.
Soon after I made emoji, my mother began using them...
...so I could imagine that emoji would be widely used in Japan,...
...but I didn't think your mom would use it.
It's this universal appeal...
...that landed them in New York's Museum of Modern Art's collection last year,...
...permanently solidifying emoji's place in art history.
So I know emojis now have grown in number, but do you have a favorite emoji?
I love the smile emoji the most.
This facial expression is easy to understand.
I found out once the smile emoji face was made,...
...I could develop other facial expressions from there.
In a way, it was a very important design,...
...and all the people of the world would like it.
I love it.